21 das glaub ich hier ist all max und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde fix
zusammen mit sturm blieben
naja ich war ändern meint kid noch hätte
kein anderes ausgewählt aber das ist
nicht schlimm denn ich kann zurückkommen
überlege ob ich irgendwas machen kann
hat er aber ein relativ schlechtes
startet ist ich brauche einfach schon
mal total sekunden
dass das gerade oder kommt ein
spannender war es erst mal eine hose für
dich und dann noch abreisen prozeus
kräften möchtest die rechts kommt bei
diesen alle volk heute alle die machen
nur mit wasser und so hier werden der
igel teilten aber ich habe dass ich die
nicht nur so ich habe auf der map
richtig ml drehmaschinen der glaubt ihr
an dass sich nebel jetzt mal besser
hatte eine angel jiménez sicher ob wir
hingehen sollten bei sonnig ich glaube
die wollen kicken ja als ob das tor
angeln ist ja geil
okay das ist die leber oder ja ich bin
der beste youtube mal gucken
christian equipment ob man hier in der
mitte wasser regeln kann du warst schon
wieder tot
ich habe die mitte so ziemlich safe bin
voll okay aber es kommt niemand wo bist
du als lebensmittel zu erhalten
nein das stimmt nicht ich habe ich schon
gesagt dass du dabei bist du nach
deutschland diese klingen patrioten
einstufte
ich war so geschockt und nicht versucht
auf der labyrinth karte und ich hab das
ende mein erstes sowas von unnötig ist
bei dieser karte also tatsächlich es ist
tatsächlich sehr geil so ich bin damit
anständige sachen glaube ich habe besser
ab aber ich weiß was ich immer so liebe
bei ward deshalb nicht bessert wird die
gar nicht an bisschen ratlos fertig es
geht dich nichts an
die machen ich mache ja du bist du so
bist du sturm wir schaffen wir dachten
erst wir sind beide so richtig gut
dieser typ der sich fast ermordet
denn einfachste equipment hat diesen
hohen runtergehen
also ich hab noch eine änderte das
eigentlich fertig du bist nicht dauernd
neu als ob ich da gerade wiedergekommen
bin ich hab schon richtig ist richtig
weh nicht der 2
aber die hab ich bin gerade etwas
mitbekommen hast ich bin und ich habe
gewonnen
runde fünf minuten zu nehmen aber es war
richtig lustig bin runter gefallen und
habe schon in der luft fall schaden
bekommen und dann bin ich irgendwie nach
10 sekunden oder sowas ist meine änderte
auf bekommt mache ich auch mir wirklich
erst hier immer so von meinen neuesten
und max inge bis zum nächsten dienst
irgendwas sagen